this is the straight edge except this is
marked so euclid's straight edge is just
a straight edge it's not a ruler and
this is a compass and you can use it to
draw circles straight edge can do the
following if you have two points in the
plane that you have previously somehow
constructed or given to you then you can
put the straight edge there and connect
them by this by a straight line and the
way we imagine it is that the straight
line is infinitely long and the paper is
infinitely big so you can't do
a line of 20 centimeters
well
sort of so that's a very good question
if you're given a line of one centimeter
by
you know by god
then
you can do a line of 20 centimeters
because you can draw one long line
and then here's my line of one
centimeter given by god and then i can
use the compass to
measure the one centimeter and then i
can
pick a starting point on my infinitely
long line and then i can put this one
centimeter there 20 times
well now i'll just do it three times
so one of the central questions
that
that people have been interested in for
a long time is
exactly what kind of length you can
construct if you're given a line segment
of one centimeter or one inch or one
unit today when you start learning
mathematics even when you're two years
old or three years old you always start
with numbers but for
euclid and people in his time it was the
opposite they thought about geometry as
being the basis of everything and they
thought about shapes points lines uh
triangles being the fundamental objects
and they thought of numbers only as
something that arise from the geometry
so the questions that they naturally ask
were a little bit different so first
i'll show you a few things that are
possible how about i
give you
a line segment of some length
and ask you to
construct a perpendicular bisector
meaning a line that's perpendicular to
this line segment and cuts it into equal
pieces i have to
open this compass quite wide because i
drew
this long line segment
so i draw
one circle arc so i do
two circle arcs the important part is
that the
width of the the radius of the circle so
the width of the compass was the same uh
when i do it from the left and when i do
it from the right and then
take the straight edge and just connect
the two points where those arcs
intersected and they will intersect
because i opened the
compass wide enough to be wider than
half
and
then this line
is a perpendicular bisector of that
so why is that i i won't maybe won't
show you all the proofs but i will show
you this one if you connect
all of these points
and what is this shape
well all of these red lines are the
radius of the circle and
those are all the same they are all the
same length because i kept the compass
the same
width the whole time and so this shape
is what's called a rhombus one of the
properties of the rhombus is that the
two diagonals are perpendicular to each
other and cut each other in half another
thing you can do this is some angle we
don't know how big it is we can't
measure it because we don't have an
angle measuring device but whatever it
is
i can bisect it meaning i can construct
a line which is right in the middle so
how do we do that we take the compass
open it to whatever width doesn't matter
draw a circle arc
and then
from where the circle arc
intersects
those uh
two lines we draw another two circle
arcs and these two have to be with the
same
radius as each other
and then where those two intersect we
draw a line
and that line will bisect the angle and
again
so let me show you one last trick that's
possible so suppose you are given a unit
square and i tell you
that
every side is of length one and i ask
whether you can
double the square meaning
construct a square which has twice the
area of this square okay so how would
that go well what we want
is a square that has twice the area
now what's the area of this square
one one because you get the area of the
square by just multiplying the
side lengths so the area of this is one
so if this has twice the area
then the area of this
is 2
and that means that we know that x
squared is 2
and so we know that x
is the square root of 2. so
how do we construct this square that's
double the size it comes down to having
to construct a
line segment of length square root 2.
and this is where
euclid's kind of question
starts to look more like your kind of
question can you do a line segment of
length 20. now his kind of question can
you do a square that's twice as big
comes down to a question
which is our kind of question can you do
a
[Music]
line segment which is of length root two
can you do a line that's root too long
yes
so
how do you do that
you draw a line okay now we want a line
perpendicular to it
pretty much anywhere
and one way we know how to do that is we
can construct perpendicular bisectors so
if i just pick two points doesn't matter
at all where they are
and then i construct a perpendicular
bisector to
that little line segment that will be a
perpendicular line and then we forget
about those points what happens if i
take my
compass so i'm given this unit segment
that's the key i know what length one is
and then if i know length what what
length one is what happens if i put
length one here
and the length one here
mark those
so this is one
this is one
can you guess what's next yeah you're
gonna do a hypotenuse exactly
so this
is a
hypotenuse and you can use the
pythagorean theorem so this is if this
is c then c squared equals 1 squared
plus 1 squared so c squared equals 2 and
so c equals the root of 2.
to finish the job well
you would have to make a square that has
this as a side length so
let's just make it a bit longer we want
perpendicular to it here and
perpendicular to it here and we know how
to do perpendiculars draw a circle arc
draw another circle arc
okay
and then you'll believe me that i can do
that on the other side as well yes we
have now three sides of the square we
just have to measure
the side length so put this
in here
this is the length root two so i measure
it on that side and then i measure it on
that side
the whole square
that is
job done
yep
so you can double square a question
that you could try figuring out is how
to triple a square
so
it it's very similar to this but it
involves a little bit of extra trickery
it's a fun problem to think about what's
the first first thing i showed you it's
uh how to bisect a segment so instead of
asking how to bisect a segment i could
ask
can you try sector segment so can you
cut a segment into three equal parts as
opposed to two equal parts the answer to
this is still yes
and it's actually pretty simple i won't
like do all the perpendiculars properly
because now you believe me that i can
construct perpendicular so i'll just do
it the shortcut way so open your
compass to any length you want put a
another line which starts at the same
point as the light segment what what the
angle is doesn't matter whatsoever put
your compass at the end and measure
this whatever length doesn't matter one
time
two times
three times
so now on this other
side i
have
constructed a line segment which is
trisected by design and then
connect these two ends
and then from this point draw a parallel
to this red line now i haven't told you
how to draw a parallel but a parallel is
what's perpendicular to a perpendicular
so what you would do is you would draw a
perpendicular to that red line here
and then you would construct a
perpendicular from this point to that
and that would be parallel
and then another one
from over here
and magic
where it intersects trisects that
original line so the next thing next
natural question i showed you how to
bisect an angle can you trisect an angle
so
i give you some angle you don't know
what the measure is because you don't
have a measuring device can you come up
with a construction which will result
in
two lines
which uh divide that angle in three
equal parts well based on everything
you've shown me so far i would have said
yes
well euclid couldn't and then for about
2 000 years people thought about this
problem before i tell you the answer let
me give you another problem so i told
you that you can you can triple a square
that's one kind of generalization of the
problem of doubling a square
it's going up in the ratio by which you
want to multiply
but you could also try going off in
dimension so square is a two dimensional
thing so instead of doubling a square
you can ask about
doubling a cube
so what does that mean well you're given
a unit cube meaning a cube whose sides
are all
length one and
what you want to try to figure out
is how to construct
another cube which has twice the volume
now what's the volume of the unit cube
warm one because you get the volume of a
cube by multiplying the side length this
side length and this side length which
are all the same because it's a cube so
that's 1 times 1 times 1 is 1.
so if we doubled it then the volume of
the new one
would be
2. so we don't know what the side length
is but we can figure it out if the side
length is y then i know that the volume
which is 2 is y times y times y so it's
y cubed well to get y we have to take
the cube root
so y equals the cube root of 2. and we
do a cube root of 2. can you do cube
roots using a compass and a straight
edge well who knows euclid couldn't and
then people thought about it for 2000
years so both of these problems euclid
couldn't crack both of them euclid
couldn't crack people were very curious
about them and many many smart people
thought about them and then in the early
1800s came along this ingenious guy
called galawa he died at age 19 in a
duel but before that he essentially
revolutionized uh algebra before he was
19 before he was 19. yeah wow
so this uh theory galois theory that he
came up with um
is now
if you're in any math program in
university you're taught this in your
say fourth year of undergraduate or
first year of graduate studies i hope
they also teach you not to have jewels
[Music]
so that gave people the tools to
eventually crack these problems and they
were
they were well not solved but it was
proven in the 1830s
that both of these are impossible and
the guy who approved both of these call
is called one cell and you can see why
they were so much harder because
when something is solvable all you need
to do is come up with a solution these
solutions they are tricky but they are
not that hard but to solve that
something is impossible that's to to
prove that something is impossible
that's hard because you can't
you know saying that i thought about it
for 10 years and couldn't do it is not a
proof maybe you're just not smart enough
so
so you have to come up with something
explicit that proves that they are
absolutely impossible and what it came
down to is exactly your kind of question
what kind of lengths can you construct
if you're given a unit segment so i for
example i showed you how to do square
root two i showed you how to do three i
show you how to do one third it turns
out that you can do all numbers that
just involve
fractions and square roots and addition
and subtraction but there's a problem
with cube roots
so what this guy proved it is that you
will never be able to do cube roots
and that can also be used to crack this
problem because trisecting an angle
somehow comes down to cube roots through
trigonometry so cube roots are the
problem cube roots aren't a big problem
but the same question applies how do you
prove you can't do cube roots how do you
prove that you can do cube roots that's
a very good question what do you use to
translate from geometry to numbers is
the main question and the the answer is
analytic geometry which you probably
encountered in high school so
coordinates you always start out with a
unit segment somehow unit segment is
always given to you to begin with and
then you want to construct other stuff
you can translate everything to the
question if you start out with a unit
segment you can construct a sys
coordinate system that has the unit
segment as like on the x-axis and then
which points can you construct from
there
starting from there so cube roots are
like an island you can't get to
exactly so so the question is you can
think about instead of which points
exactly you can construct you can you
can ask what are the coordinates of the
points that you can construct and each
basic step i told you what the basic
steps are it's like drawing a line
between two points or drawing a circle
how are new points born they are the
intersections of lines
or intersections of circles and you
might remember from high school that
when you when you solve for the
coordinates of intersecting things this
comes down to solving equations
and all of those equations will come
from equations of lines and equations of
circles
which um also you might remember from
high school or from calculus if you ever
took calculus an equation of a line is a
linear equation and an equation of a
circle is a quadratic equation so when
you solve those you're never going to
get cube roots
i'm going to fold it
and fiddle it around
okay now once i found
that uh
alignment i'm going to put my hand down
and
crease
the line
well it's much less
classical and so it's less talked about
is
is to use folding paper instead of a
straight edge and the compass